you got it you pick five three two one
Fisher random or standard and a close
one a hair shy and then another one that
you got a first so you pick way leg
fifty to five standard hang on let me
just refresh okay so those are friend
requests register let's roll here let us
roll here here we go
close that close that let's do it
challenge five standard invite coming up
coming up right now is e four and let's
see if I could get something better up
Oh what's up with that
I should I changed my mind
whoa okay
well let me tell you let me tell you
what this is different an accelerated
queenside expansion right there huh well
how do you treat this how do you treat
that
let's go let's go here
and f3 I always have to worry of like B
for now let's go with this I guess I
just have to be prepared to run run away
scared here with my night and how about
Queen e2 I might be looking for a gambit
here might be okay if they if they
pushed here I think I was considering
just playing there just castle looking
for f4 f4 my night is still protected
I'm gonna go for this now also night
here and I think that that's actually a
good idea let's see push wait a second
now I don't have anything
if I push takes the Queen is on my
Knights oh that's no good let's do this
get out any silly pins and I think I
might want to just get my king to h1 my
Khan is going very quick and what do you
do
what do you do in a situation like this
hmm a lot of central tension here coming
up maybe after a five takes takes night
here it's wait for that let's get out of
this I want them to castle first I want
to be able to have week in their
kingside so if they Castle II five and
they're not castling Bishop III really
lacking a pretty decent plan adalat
let's just kind of wait around a little
bit maybe a rookie wand coming up we'll
see is my knight gonna get shoot away I
can retreat and I'm hitting this but
then this move comes okay hang on a
second let's get this rook involved and
now there's temple gaining moves against
the Queen maybe okay let's let's go I
got to blow this position open right now
my opponent only uses a minute so let's
open up the F file and maybe induce a
weakness I think I could get that so I
want them to weak in a dark square at
this point I am opposite this bishop and
I'm looking for f7 on a week in f7 but
um let's do this first let's get rid of
that and where do I want to go my queen
probably here's best oh maybe I
shouldn't have captured well I don't
know what I'm really doing here I would
love for there to be something against
this pawn soon please Bishop h6 ship h6
missed Bishop is watching over here I'm
not too concerned about dropping that
pond maybe the computer would be taking
it let's do this because it could crunch
crunch the numbers on everything I think
Knight coming up here is gonna be a
killer isn't it are they gonna take here
first but then I get to double up this
could be a real issue really big issue
if they if I have to if I play here and
they're having to give up their dark
square bishop
Oh bad things are bound to happen where
does the RIP play here eventually I
could gain a tempo oh they're sensing
danger they're sensing danger and
they're like you know what go ahead take
my ruck because I'm fearing I'm fearing
the worst here so I should probably just
chop that guy up chop that rip right up
and then try and show some technique
here but um I don't know I don't know
about that how about I move quick how do
I do that okay let's try this my queen
can't leave the defense of this pond
which is a bit scary but um I'm
basically just watching to get here I
just want to get here okay they chopped
that so now I'm still looking for this
square because I want to come here
let's go and I want to mate on a g7
maybe I should have considered b3 okay
let's come here I think this is a case
of chasing my queen away to square it
wants to go to I think I my knight has
to be killed with the Bishop to d5 I
don't have a lot of time I want to get
Queen h6 in the night here but they
shouldn't okay how about yeah let's
let's stick around here I want to
maintain pressure on f7 or no wait there
might still be something with pond takes
and then the rook pivoting on this
square I think they have to take okay so
I'm wondering this and then rook here
with smashing through on this square
no no no no I like maintaining pressure
on f7 and let's let's guard this pond
and double up double up on a this.f file
however let's do something something
like this I gotta go quick because
they're going to be getting what they're
gonna be getting a passed pawn quickly
so I have to take action against their
king
so I think this is maybe the only plan
that I really could be running with here
so what's what's going on with that move
the Queen is I ready to pivot there and
start guarding a lot of a lot of light
squares I don't want to allow that I
think everything is good at this point
now I'm looking to just take I think
they should be maybe pushing here to buy
themselves some time this is maybe a
blunder on my part we will see we will
definitely see I think this is maybe
turning out to be a blunder on my part I
probably should have just no I couldn't
do that my rook was hit maybe there's
something better than this rook out g3
they definitely have to push their pawn
here they're dead so they did that good
move with check and I got to come back
here and now I got to get my H pond
rolling I think let's get my H pond
rolling why aren't they pushing their
pawns
that's my only fear that is definitely
my only fear and I think I'm in gate I
engage first and it's just enough time
I'm pretty sure it's just enough time or
not that's a strong move very nice very
nice I missed that little very strong
well done well done well done well done
when they're threatening mate let's try
this I did see that I am why didn't I do
something about it I was hoping they
wouldn't do anything and I'm hoping for
a perpetual actually at this point so if
pawn takes pawn takes then there's
there's something I have up my sleeve
but we're gonna see we are going to see
what do we got their time is ticking why
I was on that move played let's try this
I had anything they should just trade
Queens trade Queens and I don't have
anything
Oh what do I got 15 seconds where's the
killer move perpetual check there's a
perpetual check uh I got nothing
are they gonna lose on time no way move
oh I got no time I'm getting mated uh-oh
oh I'm in check
run King I'm down on time and position a
very good game very good game in a very
interesting idea which I'm going to be
highlighting in that middle game about
giving up the exchange very nice very
very good game let me go back there's a
lot to say on that one
mmm I should take it on a that's one
thing I'm seeing just quickly that I
could have maybe improved down on my end
let me see though happy and let's see
okay let me go back okay interesting a
very lively middle game Sicilian I'm
trying to get a 5 in so that's why I'm
doing this Knight maneuver and my
opponent is making a lot of they're
really delaying that last move King side
castle which I thought was a very
interesting idea so I I did like the
position I got I don't know if it was
necessary to give up the rook but this
is the thing I did want to emphasize
it's that you know there is I don't know
that there's really an attack against
the black king as soon as I go forward
with getting that exchange so yes it's
yes it is me going up material but
looking a bit more long-term it's like
the placement of my rooks I don't know
if I could really smash through so a
really interesting idea I think it
showed a good sense on my opponents part
that bad things could happen if they
actually just reacted to the threat like
you seeing f7 come under fire so that
was really neat to see that was a very
interesting decision and I don't know
about the night okay I guess yeah that
Knight captures all right what was the
winning plan is it the correct idea for
me to just take what the Queen like I
did should I have given up that a puns
like this should I have actually been
more stubborn I felt that it was just
not worth the time to do it it did turn
out to be very good though and these pod
moves it got really time-sensitive
really really time-sensitive really
really time-sensitive so I think this is
the the best that black could be doing
is actually just running these guys down
to try and stir up some trouble
and I wonder if there was a way to buy
time maybe oh man I maybe should have
just gone for this instead of the rook
lifts why not just actually capture
takes and then it's got to be good then
my problem was that my opponent inserted
that h4 move and it became very awkward
for me to get my rooks working so maybe
an improvement here is just snip this
guy say you know what okay yeah get your
queen here to defend but you know what
what about after let's say rook g1 now
what well actually maybe Bishop to e4
them huh maybe they would have a
defensive resource so maybe yeah just
not so easy maybe it was better that it
didn't take there I I don't I don't know
I don't have a computer here right now
to give all the answers
definitely right here I think I should
have captured that pawn might as well
just captured but this was nice if they
promoted to a queen they get made it
pretty sure yeah they get made it
somehow yeah they definitely get me to
take and then rook over here so very
slick move very aware of things is
taking like that so really interesting I
don't know I don't know what the not
sure I know it was very time to time
sensitive takes takes and I'm not
there's no way I'm better now
I think after rook age three after rook
to age three right here I think just no
actually taking okay rook AJ like I was
saying King takes Queen takes maybe
there's Perpetual checks so that's
something to be aware of that little
tactical thing maybe I have if black had
taken here I think they were well aware
of that
and I'm not sure what I have could
actually play here and look for h8 I'm
gonna get perpetual check at minimum all
right they're gonna get a perpetual
check on me at minimum I don't know
wild game a lot of fun very good